[Applaudissements]
nikos est née à paris oui après jennifer
venez tous l'association le refuge aider
le refuge
il faut un travail exceptionnel on les
aime le refuse on embrasse d'ailleurs
nicolas noguier qui doit peut-être en
train d'être en train de nous regarder
oui sur les chiens attention je vais
vous dire venez avec moi
cilic au sénat à paris cynique au sénat
à paris oui je vais ouvrir cette porte
jennifer wii est derrière cette porte
j'ai roulé remis il y aura grâce à notre
partenaire on embrasse cc et c'est pas
cher c'est essayer ces 10 cc cc kunz et
voilà c'est magnifique s'est excusé dès
qu il y aura une machine à café frigo
canapé convertible table à manger
télévision fauteuils tables basses
chaises design tapis et les mondes des
collants quête de vaisselle complet pour
les deux studios c'est trop bien le
refuge si oui les gosses est né à paris
mais nikos est d'origine grec nikos
je vous jure ne peuvent pas tout donné
ciné panne à paris nikos
il n'est pas né à chypre il n'est pas né
a fait état normal
nikos est né voilà votre studio le sucre
vous saurez tout
du jaune après tout ça au dessus voilà
les chercheurs garder votre structure
voilà mes chéris
je fais ce que je vois là nous refusons
nous sommes soir voilà vous savez je
vous aime vraiment énormément fait et
c'est vous c'est nous c'est vous ce
lundi
merci merci bien
merci mes chéris
je suis personnel
perso catégorie changez rien vous êtes
formidable jeu merci merci merci
merci merci ça me fait gerber vous vous
êtes fort hills avec josiane housse à
l'écouté sur moi vous savez qu'on se
tiendra tous fait un travail formidable
où il embrasse les nicolas on vous aime
fort voilà jennifer exceptionnel
jennifer qu'on retrouve aussi des martys
les aujourd'hui et là tout de suite on
va retrouver camille combal pide la base
je rejoins le refuge je vous laisse
votre appart un salut mes chiens et
merci